common garden vegetables sliced by a
perfectly normal car window is that
really possible when kids start playing
around with power windows watch out
that's because manufacturers often fail
to provide anti-trap protection for the
back windows if that's the case the
window will keep going up as long as
someone keeps her finger on the controls
we conducted a test
yeah I of course we're not actually
going to put our fingers in there she
says but we do have this excellent
device which measures the closing force
of the window we use it to find out with
exactly how much force the window goes
up the stack to shy be here water she's
really got to push down very hard and
that shows the enormous scale of force
involved daddy shirey hits with the
ripple car a car window that doesn't
have anti-trap protection Rises with a
closing force of up to 300 Newton's the
window is only three millimeters thick
but it can apply up to 30 kilos of
pressure on anything in its way like
fingers or other parts of the body we
carried out a test using vegetables the
cucumber would slice through cleanly so
was the horseradish as it's been kinda
musics I'm no expert on vegetable she
says but I think it's safe to say that
you need a lot of force to cut through a
7 centimeter thick horseradish what
happens when we do the same test with
the window that does have antic trap
protection the window is still moving
with a force of 50 Newtons or five kilos
but there's no damage to the tomato but
about twenty percent of all cars with
power windows don't have anti chat
protection it's easy to find out whether
yours does
a traditionally and do not use your hand
under any circumstances she says use a
tennis ball hold the tennis ball run the
window up and down either the window
stops when it touches the brawl and goes
back down or it grabs the ball and holds
it there in the latter case you don't
have anti-trap protection so kind Ankiel
shots here's more good advice this is
ganna sophistic of course you shouldn't
allow children to play unattended in
your car in the first place it's also a
good idea to find out whether your car
has a switch for blocking the rear
windows an alternate brushes and try the
worse they hinted in Cheyenne block you
and can if you do have such a system you
might be kept busy but everyone inside
will be safe